veamos este problema tenemos una masa de
12 kilogramos que está encima de una
mesa y de su lado izquierdo está atada a
una cuerda que pasa por una polea y que
está atada a una masa de 3 kilogramos
del lado derecho tenemos que también hay
otra cuerda que pasa por otra polea y
está atada a una masa de 5 kilogramos
aquí la pregunta es cuál es la
aceleración que hay en esta masa de 12
kilogramos y vamos a hacer este problema
aún más difícil digamos que el
coeficiente de fricción cinética entre
esta masa y la mesa es igual
0.1 y ahora tenemos un problema bastante
complicado si es que fuéramos a
resolverlo por la forma difícil y la
forma difícil es aplicar la segunda ley
de newton para cada una de las masas
involucradas en este problema lo cual
por lo menos nos dejaría un sistema de
tres ecuaciones y tres incógnitas ya que
tendríamos tres aceleraciones diferentes
y además dos tensiones diferentes la
atención de la izquierda tiene un valor
diferente a la atención de la derecha ya
que se trata de cuerdas diferentes sería
la misma tensión si ésta fuera la misma
cuerda pero no lo es este problema
estaría bastante difícil y tendríamos
muchos problemas potenciales de álgebra
aquí y para evitarlos eso vamos a
resolver el problema usando la forma
fácil y la forma fácil es considerar
todas estas masas o todos estos objetos
como si fueran uno solo
y podemos hacerlo ya que todas estas van
a tener la misma magnitud de aceleración
a esto le llamamos así la magnitud de
aceleración del sistema ya que cada una
de estas cajas va a tener la misma
magnitud de aceleración aunque algunas
tengan aceleraciones negativas y otras
tengan aceleraciones positivas como
estas de acá pero todas van a tener la
misma magnitud de la aceleración ya que
suponemos que estas cuerdas no se van a
romper si se rompieran entonces ya
tendríamos otras magnitudes de
aceleración pero estas cuerdas no se van
a romper ni se van a estirar o al menos
eso suponemos y la forma de trabajar con
esto es imaginar que estas tres cajas
son un solo objeto de manera que ya no
me tengo que preocupar por estas fuerzas
internas estas tensiones son fuerzas
internas y estas fuerzas internas no
hacen que se acelere el sistema solo las
fuerzas externas pueden hacerlo así que
vamos a encontrar la fuerza neta externa
las fuerzas externas que traten de
acelerar el sistema o se resistan a la
aceleración de este y vamos a dividirlas
entre la masa total
esto simplemente es la segunda ley de
newton aplicada como si todo esto fuera
un solo objeto grande bueno cuáles son
las fuerzas externas una de las fuerzas
que hacen que se mueva este sistema es
la fuerza de gravedad en nuestra masa de
los cinco kilogramos esta fuerza de
gravedad va a jalar este sistema hacia
abajo en esta dirección esta es la
fuerza que va a mover a todo el sistema
si yo dejara ir todas estas cajas
comenzarían a moverse en esta dirección
ya que la fuerza de gravedad aquí con
esta masa de 5 kilogramos es mayor que
la fuerza de gravedad en la masa de tres
kilogramos vamos a considerar la
positiva ya que todo lo que vaya con la
dirección del movimiento va a ser
positivo y es más fácil así que aquí
tenemos más 5 kilogramos
x 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
esto es esta fuerza de gravedad hay
alguna otra fuerza que esté propiciando
este movimiento pues no no hay ninguna
otra fuerza externa y hay alguna fuerza
que esté oponiéndose al movimiento del
sistema sí sí la hay y es la fuerza de
gravedad en esta caja de masa de tres
kilogramos ésta está moviéndose en
sentido contrario a la de todo el
sistema por lo que esta va a ser una
fuerza negativa todo el sistema se está
moviendo hacia la derecha pero esta
fuerza se está moviendo hacia la
izquierda así que la vamos a restar y es
menos tres kilogramos la masa por 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado y habrá
alguna otra fuerza que esté evitando
este movimiento pues quizás ustedes
pueden pensar que la fuerza de gravedad
esta caja de 12 kilogramos podría
influir en este movimiento pero no esta
fuerza es perpendicular al movimiento
del sistema si esta fuerza tuviera una
dirección en este sentido o en este otro
entonces si la tomaríamos en cuenta para
este movimiento pero no es así pero esta
fuerza de gravedad está equilibrada por
la fuerza normal así que no la voy a
tomar en cuenta entonces hay alguna
fuerza asociada con esta masa de los 12
kilogramos que esté evitando el
movimiento del sistema si si la hay y de
hecho permítanme hacer un poco más de
espacio voy a mover todo esto para que
pueda poner lo que falta muy bien ahora
si tenemos suficiente espacio y que otra
fuerza tenemos que va a estar en contra
de este movimiento pues vamos a tener la
fuerza de fricción entre esta masa y la
mesa ya que tenemos este coeficiente de
fricción cinética así que vamos a tener
una fuerza que va
en esta dirección esta fuerza de
fricción cinética
efe ks que es igual a nunca por la
fuerza normal y es así como encontramos
la fuerza normal así que aquí arriba
vamos a tener menos muca que es ese
coeficiente de flexión cinética que es
de 0.1 multiplicada por la fuerza normal
que está actuando en esta masa de 12
kilogramos que va a ser igual a 12 por
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado y
ustedes me pueden decir a ver un momento
estás usando 12 por 9.8 esto es la
fuerza de gravedad porque estás usando
la fuerza de gravedad aquí bueno resulta
que no estamos usando esta fuerza tal
cual esta fuerza de fricción depende de
esta fuerza de gravedad así que aquí
sólo vamos a usar la fuerza horizontal
que evita lo que se está oponiendo a
este movimiento
eso es que la ponemos aquí y la ponemos
con signo negativo pero este es una
fuerza horizontal
simplemente coincide que esta fuerza
horizontal depende de la fuerza vertical
que es la fuerza normal y es por eso que
la multiplicamos por este punto 1 que es
el coeficiente de fricción cinética esto
transforma a esta fuerza vertical que no
está evitando que se mueva o que se
detenga el sistema en una fuerza
horizontal que si está evitando que se
mueva el sistema está evitando que se
acelere el sistema y es por eso que la
ponemos con signo negativo
esto lo vamos a dividir entre la masa
total del sistema que es de 3 kilogramos
más 12 kilogramos más 5 kilogramos es
decir 20 kilogramos
y si resuelvo todo esto me va a dar que
esta magnitud de la aceleración del
sistema es 0.3 92 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y esto es una forma muy rápida
de encontrar este valor básicamente lo
resolvimos en una sola línea con menos
probabilidades de equivocarnos en los
signos si escribimos todo esto bien
resolveremos todo en una sola línea a
diferencia de tener tres ecuaciones con
tres incógnitas por lo que tendremos un
menor margen de error esto es genial
aunque tengan cuidado al aplicarlo
recuerden que por ejemplo la aceleración
en esta masa de 5 kilogramos va a ser de
menos 0 punto 392 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y es negativo porque se está
acelerando hacia abajo la aceleración en
la masa de los tres kilogramos va a ser
positivo cero punto 392
metros por segundo al cuadrado positivo
porque va con dirección hacia arriba su
aceleración y la aceleración en la masa
de 12 kilogramos es positiva y es de 0.3
cientos 92 metros por segundo al
cuadrado porque todo lo que va hacia la
derecha por convención tiene signo
positivo